Two.
Do you have a reservation?
Superman.
I don't see anything.
Might be under "The Man of Steel".
Man of Steel, Man of Steel. Oh yeah, Man of Steel. Right here. This way.
Man of Steel.
Why do you do that?
Wanna sit by the kitchen?
No.
No, you don't.
I mean, how could they put this much mayonnaise on tuna fish and expect people to eat it.
What do you care? You're invulnerable to harm.
It's not harm, it's too rich. Makes me queasy.
Send it back.
Nah.
You got a little.
Huh?
Napkin?
Why? It's impervious to stain.
Excuse me, Superman?
Yes.
I don't know if you remember me, Barry Cats? You saved my life once.
I was hanging from a train trestle.
Yeah, sure, sure. How are you?
Terrific. Great. I don't want to interrupt your meal, I just wanted to say thanks again.
No, not a problem. It's good to see you again, Barry.
He's the best. You're good, too.
Thank you.
Who was that?
No idea.
So, you wanna help me hook up this DVD?
I thought we were going cycling?
Nah, cycling with you is no fun.
Why not?
It's just not.
Anyway, I wanna hear this thing. It's got surround sound.
I've always wanted that.
You've got super hearing.
Yeah, but it's not surround sound. I mean, surround sound! It's like, it's like you're there.
What are you talking about?
So, did you go bowling with those people last night?
No, I stayed home. I watched that rebound wedding.
Oh!